Allahbar. Allahbar.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Shah, a shadow
Muhamad.
[Silence]
Madam
Heat. Heat.
[Silence]
Hal Father. Yeah.
Allah Akbar.
[Silence]
Allah.
Oh, alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Abdul Allah subhana wa tala
regime. Was
[Silence]
My dear brothers, respected elders,
beloved youth, mothers and sisters, we
thank Allah subhana wa ta'ala for
keeping us alive one more day on the
path
Islam in allowing me and you to enter
his house and worship him in the manner
that pleases him. I ask Allah subhanaa
tala except for me and except from you
that little do his path. Amen. And I
bear witness there is no deity worthy of
worship except for Allah subhana tala
and prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam is his last and final
messenger. For surely Allah subhanaa
tala choose to guide can misguide and
whoever he chooses to misguide nik can
guide him back to the path and we seek
refuge in Allah from darkness of
ourselves and evil of deeds for Allah is
all knowing and allseeing what his
creation
does indeed from the wisdoms of Allah
subhana tala that Allah subhanaa tala
almighty has ordained three types of
inner selves that influence people at
different times throughout their lives
depending on how much control a person
allows them to have the self that
commands evil, the self that blames and
the tranquil
self. To clearly understand one's own
state and
determine where one stands among these
three inner selves, it is essential to
open an important door. A door that
should never be
closed or worse yet locked entirely and
forgotten about it. This is the door the
door this door is the principle of
self-critique being honest and candidate
candid with one's self so that one can
recognize points of deficiency and
correct them with the blaming inner self
and identify those
points of correctness and enhance them
with the tranquil self. Thus
initializing both of these inner self,
they tighten the reigns on the inner
self that commands evil so that it
cannot
reach what it would otherwise have
reached without self-scrutiny and
holding themselves accountable with
complete
impartiality. As such, scrutinizing
oneself is one of the most noblest and
courageous tasks despite its b despite
its burden on one's soul and breaking of
its pride to compel it towards what is
right. Through self-examination, we
confront our shortcomings and strive for
self-improvement. Through it, mistakes
are corrected. The ugly is replaced with
beautiful and the bad with the good. And
no one person knows no one knows a
person's fault and mistake better than
themselves. No matter how many excuses
they make is Allahh has reflected that
in Allahh says but a man will be a
witness against himself even if he pre
he be pre if he even if he presents his
excuses. So a day, the day, the greatest
day where the eyes will not have the
ability to lift up and the heads will be
down and people will be in fear is the
day of the day of judgment. We're all
the limbs that we have that has forced
us, me and you, to do evil and seek
evil for a pleasure that may last for 5
minutes or 5 hours or an entire
lifetime. And we will have to answer for
that. And that day, regardless of what
we have and how many locks we put on our
tongues, Allah will make us speak. Our
our limbs will testify against us.
The
same people that we did evil for and we
did all these things and transgressions
and we stole money and we took people's
property and we lied and we cheated and
we stole everything will be turned
against us in an instance. We ask Allah
subhanaa tala from that
time we are all in a dire neon gates in
self- scrutiny without hesitation fear
or pro or pro or pro
procrastination by focus focusing
intently on examining and cleansing and
cleansing ourselves we overlook others
faults and instead recognize the flaws
within
ourselves indeed Allah Almighty's words
are true when he said
I swear by the self reproaching soul, a
soul that blames yourself.
And at times when talking to folks and I
mentioned this during the month of
Ramadan, we are more aware of our
constant struggle with our nefs in the
month of
Ramadan because we are more focused of
all the bad that exists.
So controlling my naps when I have
50,000 options driving to work to pull
into a gas station to get a cold drink
or eat whatever I want and nobody's
looking at me where I work in a
workplace where there's no Muslims
around and I can eat and fill my belly
up with whatever I want to. But we stop
ourselves. So we are more focused in
that blessed month and we're more
focused. You know if you think about it
a lot of times the conversation that
happens is the is the shaitan really
locked up? Yes it is locked up because
that's why you're recognizing your own
flaws. You're more
cognizant of what's
happening. You're co- cognizant of your
eyes wandering. You're more cognizant of
your tongue wandering off. You're more
cognizant of your limbs that are acting
against you for the will of Allah
subhana
tala and you have that inner thing that
constantly tells
you you didn't pray salah today it's
month of Ramadan you just fasted all day
without drinking food and water and
theam reminds us is that a person who
just refrained from water and drink all
day. He has nothing but give himself
hunger and thirst all day. There is
nothing else for him. I didn't I didn't
I didn't make myself busy with the
Quran. I didn't engage in myself with I
didn't engage myself doing good deeds. I
didn't engage myself. And that's
the that's the that's constantly mocking
you and telling
you and we have to say at times
alhamdulillah for that because if it
wasn't that for that naps will be gone
completely. So if you have that nef
of that's
constantly mocking you and reminding you
thank Allah subhana wa
tala because the the the crit the the
critical point comes into our lives when
that nef stops telling us then the nef
is so dead that it doesn't even speak
up. And there is clear evidence of
importance of self-critique, critique,
self-lame, and self-correction given
them constant attention without neglect.
Allah does not swear by his book except
by something great significance in and
and in his interpretation in the Quran
cited saying by Allah we do not see the
believer except blaming himself and what
is intended with my word. What did I
intend by eating? What did I intend my
with my thoughts? Whereas a
transgressors pro proceeds without
blaming
himself we ask Allah's protection from
that
time that condition when you see folks
they eat they drink whatever without
accountability. It reminds me of a
beautiful story that we have mentioned
as some of the some of the narrators of
the Quran have mentioned the story.
There was a man a long time ago and it's
not the time of but in the previous
nations who was a
murderer who was a murderer. So he went
to he he he he Allah subhana t put in
his heart he had killed 99 people
99 people he had taken the lives
unjustly.
So one day
his finally woke up and blamed
him and said, "You are such a filthy
person. You have killed 99 folks without
anything."
And then he goes into a
spiral and inshallah if we have time
we'll talk about it because that's one
of the issues that we get into is that
how do we hap handle
that because if we don't control it then
you go into a deep spiral within
yourself of a self-lame and hatred that
you cannot climb out of from but he has
this talk with himself. He says I'm such
a bad person I need to go ask for
forgiveness. So he travels and you know
he asks some folks and they say look
we're not educated folks but if you
travel further down there's a small town
there's a there's a sheh and there and
there somebody can help you. So this man
travels down there he meets somebody
me and he asked them he's I
have 99 cents what's going to happen he
said you're in
jennam door closed. So the man thinks
about himself he said look I already
have 99 let me kill one more make it
100. So he kills that guy too. He makes
a 100
even after he kills that guy. Now he
goes back into that same
process. Now he's blaming himself again.
He's his inner self is calling him out.
He's saying, "Look what you have
done." And then he has that trigger
again and he says, "Okay, I need to I
need to to do
something." So he then asks some more
folks and they say, "Look, we're we
don't know anything about what Allah can
do and not do, how Toba works. you need
to go ask somebody who is a really good
scholar, but that person is further down
in another town. You need to go see this
big scholar. We we cannot help you. As
this man is
traveling, the time of death is written
for
him. And he dies on the way to ask this
person how to make Toba to Allahh. A
toba, a sincere Toba to Allah.
So the angels descend from both sides,
the good and the bad because they want
to take the person to hell or they take
the person as Allahh says in the Quran,
right? If you are a good soul, pure
soul, the angel will come down and say,
"Oh beautiful soul, come back.
Return to your Lord with your own
willingness. And a soul that is dirty
and filthy, it's dragged
out. May Allah subh protect us. It's
literally dragged out out of that human
being and then taken
for brothers, if you can move forward
with a spot in front of you. Just move
forward, please. We're getting a little
crowded in the back road there.
So now the angels have a fight amongst
their hand. The angels who are saying
this is we'll take it. There's an angels
were saying no no no this is a a soul.
This is a soul that's not worthy. We
take him and there's a fight. So
eventually Allah subhana t you know has
to be the judge and he says what's going
on. Gabriel is asked what's going on.
Jabra is requesting ya Allah this is the
matter. We cannot decide what's going
what the angels are are fighting amongst
themselves. They say measure the
distance that where he killed the last
person to where he was going to make
Toba. If that distance is
shorter, he will be forgiven in Jenna.
If that distance is greater, how far is
it for him? Allahh ordains the earth to
shrink a little bit. and the earth is
shrunk on the side. That distance
between the person where he died and
where he's making Toba is now
shorter and Allah forgives
him. Now don't come to me and say she I
don't think that's a true story or not.
The the the idea and the mentioning of
these stories is not to tell you it's
true or not. is to teach a lesson for
us is that that's that guy had a
self-laming soul that we're talking
about the self-critiquing soul that
urged him to do better. And through that
nia and through that
intention, he continued on a journey
that became the way to for him to enter
the paradise. Even though he's killed
how many folks? 100
folks. has killed 100 people without any
justification. And that's the soul that
we required to reach. That's the soul we
want to
reach. Let me finish the third stage.
the time is running away from me as as
always. The third stage is being
cautious not to repeat the same mistakes
for the believer is not stung from the
same source. Twice that hadith reminds
us. This means learning from one's
errors to prevent future missteps. Also,
one should be aware of falling into
what others have fallen into. For the
happy are those who takes heat from
others and the wretched are the those
who fail to learn from others and
persist upon their mistakes. A
self-critiing soul does not make ex
does not mean excessively reproaching
oneself to the point of
stifling or psychological burnout or
becoming consumed or among the doom.
There's a difference between
conservative
criticism which is which moves one from
pursuing from purging to adoring from
bad to good from good to better and
self-destructive criticism that leads to
despair. And one of the best tools that
Shayan has amongst his arsenal is coming
to one and telling them that you are
worthless. There is nothing left for
you.
So I mentioned this and this is by the
way very common example. I mentioned it
just to close out the first part of the
sermon. A person misses a salah or does
a
sin. A person commits a sin. Now it's
time for
salah. You know so a person is not you
know fully connected with the dean.
Suppose they had a night out and they're
coming back from a party and now it's
early morning, right? And it's a fudah
and they're just leaving the club and
the adan is happening
for now even though he can go make and
enter the masid and he thinks about it
and the shaitan comes and starts
whispering the waswas and he says look
at yourself or you want to go pray salah
now all night you were partying in there
but now you want to go pray salah Allah
does not need salah from you You're a
filthy person. Allah does not need
anything from you. And the person
thinks, "Wow, subhan Allah, I'm such a
pious person now that Allah does not
need me out of selfrespect, out of
respect for Allah, I'm not going to go
read the salah because I don't want to
be that dirty person going to to to pray
salah in the in the masid." We
understand this concept,
right? And then fud is gone. Vhar comes
along. He's still in that cycle. He
leaves the second salah, the third
salah, the fourth salah, the fifth
salah. And then same thing happens
again. He's out again with his buddies.
He misses. He misses. And then the cycle
starts again. Fud comes along and he's
I don't want to do it. I just was
outside. I was hanging out. I was doing
this. I don't want to read salah. All
the while thinking that he is preventing
him himself the dirty person that he is
the filthy human being he is from
entering the masid. Nothing could be
opposite from the truth or the facts is
that Allah subhana t is waiting for that
person to come
back. Allah is waiting for this person
to come back to the masjid. But what
happens at the end is that person
spirals further and further and further
away from his dean
constantly because now he's in
hopelessness. He cannot bring himself to
face his
lord where Allah subhana t says if you
come I will forgive all the
sins. As the hadith mentioned, if you
prayed, everything that happened between
and minus the major sins, Allah
forgives. From whatever sins might be
committed, Allah forgives minus the
major sins from whatever you committed,
Allah forgives. Minus the major sins
from to anything you've done is
forgiven.
So we have to be careful when we turn
back to Allah subhana tala. We ask
Allahh we ask Allahh to grant us wisdom
in his dean. We ask Allahhat and before
he takes from takes us from this earth.
We ask Allahh not that he does not take
us from this earth until Allah himself
is satisfied with us. And that when he
takes us from this earth when in the
form of submission to Allah subhana tala
in the best form may Allah take our
souls from this earth when we are in the
to Allah subhana tala and the words that
come out of our mouth.
left.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. Part of what we talked
about the week
before is becoming mindful of our
blessing upon us from Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. And part of that blessing is
having the vision and the view of
self-critique of
oneself. We have to we have to have that
accountability.
It is from the blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and this is
mentioned in narrations that if Allah
decided that there will be a bad odor
from us because of our
sins a bad odor because of our sins not
because we're in the sun outside or
because I have too much
sweating wall we would not be able to
sit with each
other and the dilemma for the
wasallam majority of us today is not the
sins that we do
openly. It is the sins that we do
privately behind closed
doors. But remembering and connecting
with Allah subhana wa ta'ala at a
constant pace.
Regardless of how low you think of
yourself, you must return to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and seek his
mercy.
Ifam the best human being to walk upon
this earth and Allah has forgiven his
prior and his coming sins. Not that we
are
sayingatam had some
sins. Allah has given him that much
leeway that he has his previous and the
and the the the future all forgiven. He
is asking from to for Toba from Allah
subhanaa tala 80 times plus a day. So
what are we and
you when our dealings are tainted and
shaded where our eyes are wandering our
tongues are not truthful our hands are
committing sins.
So what are we and who are
we? So we need to connect with Allah
subhana tala and we need to stop this
disparity amongst
oursel Allah subhanaa tala forgives it
all. Allahh forgives every
single you know transgression that we
have done in a hadith the mention in
authentic narration it's mentioned when
a person comes to Allahhaala and he
comes to return to Allahh and ask for
forgiveness Allah subhana tala openly
and cheerfully mentions to my servant
has realized that he has a lord today he
has come and asked for forgiveness I
make you my witness I have forgiven him
and whatever he does the person commits
the second sin same person he goes back
and commits a sin and he comes back to
Allah subhanaa tala and he asks for
forgiveness Allahh then mentions again
to his angels my servant has realized
that he has a lord and he's come back to
me I make you my witness I have forgiven
his sin the person goes on and again he
commits more sin then he comes back to
Allahh Allahh says to his angels my my
servant has realized that he has a
master he has a lord and he has come
back and asked for forgiveness I make
you my witness
I have forgiven his sin and whatever he
does I have
forgiven. When there's such a loving
Allah subhana tala, how dare we not
return back to Allah subhana tala? What
has brought us to this level of
disparity? We ask every single person
for
everything. Yet we fail to ask Allah
subhana tala who created us. Look, go
and Google the odds of you being born. I
just want you to Google those odds. What
was the odds of you being born in this
world and growing up to be today's age?
Just look up the odds of being born.
Forget about where you're at
today. It's a million to one
odds. But Allah
subhanaa has blessed it upon us. I
finished
witham mentioned and mentioned Muslim
Strive for what benefits you. Seek help
from Allah subhana tala and do not be
helpless. The aim of the was to bring an
attention to ours the three
kinds and there are three kinds of the
the nees we talked about today. But it's
nothing to be despared about. There's
nothing to be in a in a in a in a in a
stagnant pond and think Allahh has
forgiven us or Allah has forsaken us.
Allah never forsakes us. We are the ones
who have forsaken Allahh. We ask Allahh
to bring him back return him return us
back to Allah in the best of the forms
and not through his
or we ask Allahh to make us in
the divide that unites hearts and not
divide hearts. We ask Allahh to make us
from the people who unite not divide
we ask Allahh to make us the flag
bearsers and the flag carriers of
theham. We ask Allahh to make us a
lighthouse in the darkness of the dark
night and guide those brothers and
sisters around us to the better of the
path.
Amen.
Fore become.
[Silence]
for the Quran.
Please move forward. There's a line
behind you.
[Silence]
Sh. Allah
Senior lines, please fill the gaps in
between. This also applies to sisters
too, by the way. It's just not for men's
too. Please fill out the gaps if you
have any gaps. If the chairs are not
needed, please remove the
chairs. We ask Allahh for his mercy
and
Allah.
Alhamdulillah. Amen.
[Silence]
Amen.
Fore! Foreign!
Foreign!
[Silence]
for in
for
them. Allahbar
[Silence]
Simulk.
Allahbar. Allahbar.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Amen. Amen.
[Silence]
Allahbar.
Amen. Allahbar.
[Silence]
Allahbar Allah.
I just need a couple of minutes of
your time inshallah and then you are
free to go after that. just want to
share some sad news that we got right
before the jama. I
immediat 17 is the pink looking masjid
that you see right next to the freeway.
A big a huge masjid that you see. He
just passed
away. Unfortunately most of us cannot
make it because the salah is taking
place right now. We ask Allah subhana
tala that he elevate his statuses and
forgive his shortcomings and grant him
for we ask Allahh provide his family
with and may Allah subh provide sheh in
the hereafter with the family that's
better than the family he had and the
children he had better than this and all
the sustenance that was better than this
Allah. , as far as Aza, they have Aza
scheduled today.
, I just don't know. I think it's at
ICC, , or sorry, , at the same
place, Islamic Center, , Community
Center of Phoenix, ICCP. I'm not too
sure. Inshallah, we'll try to get those
details and we'll push it out through
WhatsApp chats that you have. , just a
reminder, inshallah, Rahma Academy is
currently enrolling for summer programs.
Sunday school will have summer program
announced as well. So if you have kids
who possibly can go inshallah we'll be
more than delighted to take it. we
will offer u scholarships on Sunday
school site inshallah. So if you are you
know a need for it or eligible you know
somebody who can use it let us know
inshallah we can we can do it. there
are a couple of few requests I want to I
want to be sure my sisters upstairs can
hear me. The the design